- [Jason] So, Andy
Richter, thank you so much
for being here for the hour.
- Thank you for having me.
It was, it was great.
I had a good time.
- [Jason] Yeah, It's good, right?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- [Jason] It's fun.
It was painless. Painless.
I expected more pain.
- [Jason] Good.
- Yeah, I just want to say, uh,
I saw "New York Minute" last week, and uh,
- [Andy] Oh, here comes the pain.
- Yeah. It's pretty unfunny.
- [Andy] (laughs)
- I mean all, when I say "pretty unfunny,"
I mean really, really unfunny.
- [Jason] What's "New York Minute"?
- It's a movie I did with the Olsen twins.
- [Jason] What is it?
- A number of years ago.
- I don't know why (mumbles)
- [Jason] Wait, wait, what's the movie?
- It's called "New York Minute."
The Olsen twins, it was a feature film
that they did and, and I was in it.
- I guess it was an artistic choice
to do an Olsen twins movie.
Oh, and also, the Chinese accent you did
was really offensive.
- [Jason] Wait, you do
a Chinese accent in it?
- [Andy] Yeah. I had a...
- [Dennis] Yeah a really
offensive Chinese accent.
- Nah, it wasn't
that offensive.
- Okay, what are you doin'?
What are you doing?
- [Andy] It was
kind of funny.
- What are you doing?
Why are you doing this, why are you,
Why are you doing this?
Don't do this, this is our guest
- I just thought I'd
brought it up, that's all.
- Don't be...
- Why would a man your, a
man with gray in his beard
be watching the Olsen twins movie
just a couple of weeks ago?
- Oh, why would a man your age
be doing the Olsen twins movie?
- [Andy] No questions but why,
- [Jason] Dennis, stop.
- [Andy] would that...
- Just stop, okay?
Dennis, just do the...
- [Andy] That perv, or some
kind of perv accessory?
- Andy, I'm really sorry.
Just do the technical end
- [Andy] It's alright
of the podcast.
Anyway...
- [Dennis] I'm sorry (mumbles)
- Anyway, Andy, it's been a great hour,
you know Andy and Sarah were, Dennis,
they were up at my house
the other day, and...
- We had a very nice time.
- What a beautiful wife, I mean --
- Oh, well thank you.
- She is...
- I hope she didn't have a
little too much to drink did she?
- She had a little bit to drink.
- Yeah, yeah she gets a little --
- She's fun.
- just a little crazy.
She likes your white wine.
- [Jason] Yeah, she does.
- Sometimes, you know,
she gets a little feisty,
but, you know it's got its upside too,
sometimes it makes her a little frisky.
- [Jason] Really?
- Yeah. So I get to, you know,
I get the benefits of that sometimes.
The insistence.
- Like sex? She's sexual?
She's a little...gets horny?
- I, maybe, have been pulled
into a couple of bathrooms
here and there, um,
which is really
- Are you serious?
Like a party?
- [Andy] A joy.
Yeah, yeah.
I...But, that, I...
- Wait a minute, wait a minute, so Sarah,
nice Sarah,
- Yes, my wife.
- The wonderful,
- Yes, I...
- charming Sarah
- Yes, now I, yes, I...
will go to a party
- Oh, I'm in
so much trouble for saying this.
- And pull you
into the bathroom
- Yes, yes
- and you'll have sex in the bathroom?
- I will leave it up to your imagination
as to what we do, but...
- I love, I mean I just, I
love her so much more now
Oh God, I thought...
- Well, don't love her
too much.
- I thought I loved her a lot
- Yeah
- And now, she's like a ten in my book
- Great. Okay.
- [Dennis] Shit
- [Jason] Sarah!
- [Dennis] Fuck!
Fuck!
- What?
- Shit! It's gone.
Fuck!
Oh, no no no don't crash!
It crashed!
Fuck! Fuck!
Fuck it crashed!
It's gone!
Everything we just did!
- [Jason] Alright,
alright, so take it easy
- You fucking take it easy!
You fucking take it easy!
- [Jason] What is? Calm down!
- Right, take it easy?
- It's gone!
- [Jason] Stop yelling.
- Fuck, man!
Fuck!
Who? Fuck!
- Dennis, will you stop,
will you calm down?
- Shit! You don't even
know what I'm doing!
You don't even know what crash means!
You don't even give a shit
- [Jason] Yeah I do know what,
I know what crash means.
- Neither does this fucking asshole.
Jesus Christ, it's fucking gone.
- [Dennis] No fucking way, fuck!
- Is, is he okay?
- Oh, yeah.
He, uh, he flips out
every once in a while.
- Yeah, yeah.
He might need some help.
- He's actually really
good technically, so...
- I wanted to ask you before I go
it's totally my fault, I brought it up,
but could you please cut out the part
where I talk about the,
my wife and the drinking
and the sex, and the...
I should not have
brought it up, I'm sorry.
But I do not want that on the
podcast, if that's possible.
- I totally understand, of course
and you know what, the
whole episode is lost, so...
- Oh, so he wasn't able to get it...
He was...
- No, no.
- It's gone.
- Yeah, so I don't even
have to cut anything out
cause nothing, nothing is going out.
- So this is all been a waste
of everyone's time, then.
- Yeah.
- Wow. That, that is, a drag.
That is a real...
- Yeah, I know, I...
And I would say, let's go back in
and do it again,
- No, no no, I, no
I can't, I can't
- Yeah, of course.
I, I get it.
- Alright, well...
Thanks.
See you later.
- See, see you later, Andy!
(upbeat music)